- Welcome everyone to the Yale Conference
on Japanese Soft Power in East Asia.
My name is Dan Mattingly,
I'm assistant professor
in the Department of Political Science
here at Yale.
I'm also a member of the
Council on East Asian studies.
And I'm delighted to welcome
everyone to this event.
We'd like to thank especially
the consulate general of Japan in Boston
for generous funding,
and especially, Setsuo
Ohmori, the consul general
of the consul general of Japan in Boston.
So this is a workshop on
soft power competition
and especially Japanese
soft power in East Asia.
Soft power competition
in East Asia, I think,
is of growing importance as Japan,
a long time soft power
superpower in the region
now faces a China which
has considerable ambitions
to overtake Japan and the United States
as a significant soft power player,
especially in East Asia.
So in this workshop of two papers,
we're going to start with the logic
of soft power competition
evidenced in East Asia.
We'll have a brief break
from 08:25 to 08:40,
a short intermission,
and then we'll have the paper,
"Does public diplomacy
sway foreign opinion?
"Identifying the effect
of high level visits."
So we have a really fantastic,
amazing crew of panelists
who are a part of this.
So I'd like people to go around
and briefly introduce
themselves in alphabetical order
by last name.
So I'd like to start with...
If you could just briefly identify
who you are and the
institution you're from,
starting with Amy Catalinac from NYU.
- Hi everyone, Amy Catalinac from NYU.
Long story about how my career is
the product of soft power efforts
by Japan and New Zealand omitted,
but happy to share that at this time.
- Great, thanks.
Next, Charles.
- I'm Charles Crabtree,
assistant professor of
government at Dartmouth College.
Really happy to be here.
- Graham, if you wouldn't mind.
- Hi, I'm Graham Davis,
professor of international security
at the University of York in the UK.
- Okay, Christina.
- Christina Davis, professor of government
and director of the program
on US-Japan relations
at Harvard University.
- Okay, and if our panelists
can see the list now
that's in the chat.
You can also just jump in.
So Benjamin Goldsmith is next.
- Yeah, good morning from Australia.
I'm Ben Goldsmith, professor
of political science
in the School of Politics
and International Relations
at the Australian National University
and also head of school.
Thanks very much for inviting me
and our paper.
- Hi, I am Naima Green-Riley,
I'm a PhD candidate at Harvard University
and really excited about
this entire program
because I was once,
in a former career,
a public diplomacy officer
at the state department.
- So I'm Yusaku Horiuchi,
professor of government
and Mitsui Professor of
Japanese Studies at Dartmouth,
and I'm also very happy
to attend this conference
and presenting our new paper.
- Hi, I'm Trevor Incerti.
I'm a PhD candidate at Yale university.
I am currently a visiting research fellow
at the University of Tokyo
Institute of Social Science
and an associate researcher at
the Waseda University
Institute of Political Economy.
- Hi, I'm Changwook Ju,
or Chang if that's more
convenient for you to pronounce.
I'm a third year PhD student
in political science here at Yale
and I study security and military studies
(indistinct)
- I don't have a list in my hand
but my last name start from a K,
so probably me.
Tae-Ho Kim.
I'm from Sungkonghoe University,
South Korea, Seoul.
I'm a professor of political science
and the Dean of Graduate
School for National Strategy.
Good to meet you everybody
and look forward to good
papers and discussions.
- Good morning, everyone.
I'm Tetsuro Kobayashi
from Department of Media and Communication
at the City University of Hong Kong.
I study political communication,
political psychology and public opinion
in East Asian countries.
Good to see you.
- Hi, I'm another Kobayashi,
Yoshi Kobayashi.
And I am an associate professor
at the University of Leeds in the UK.
- Hi everyone, my name is Tom Lee.
I'm an assistant professor of politics
at Pomona College out in California.
Happy to be here.
- Hi everyone, I'm Adam Liff,
The associate professor of East Asia
and international relations
at the Hamilton Lugar School
at Indiana university,
where I also run the 21st
Century Japan Politics
and Society Initiative.
Glad to be here.
- Good evening, I'm Sijeong Lim.
I'm an associate professor
at the division of international studies
at Korea University.
- We will joined later by Jennifer Lind,
professor of government
at Dartmouth College.
- And I'm Phillip Lipscy.
I'm associate professor
at University of Toronto,
where I also direct the
Center for the Study
of Global Japan.
Great to see you all.
- I'm Kelly Matush.
I'm an assistant professor
of political science
at Florida State University.
- I forgot to introduce myself.
Again, I'm Daniel Mattingly.
I'm an assistant professor
of political science at Yale university.
- Hi everyone, I'm Colin Moreshead.
I'm a second year student
in the political science
department at Yale.
And I'm so glad to see all of you here
after having corresponded
with most of you.
So glad you're all here.
- Good morning, everybody.
I'm Kenneth McElwain.
I'm professor at the
Institute of Social Science
at the University of Tokyo.
Great to see everybody.
- So we have a Professor Nye also as well.
- Sorry, my participants
list is not alphabetical.
I'm Joe Nye,
former Dean at the Kennedy School
and now a research professor
at the Kennedy School of
Government at Harvard.
- Hello, I'm Maria Repnikova
I'm an assistant professor
of global communication
at Georgia State University
and currently Wilson fellow.
I'm writing two books
on Chinese soft power.
Really excited to be here, thank you.
- Hi, I'm Daniel Smith.
I'm a associate professor of government
at Harvard University.
Thank you for having me
participate in this event.
- Morning, my name is Atsushi Tago.
I'm Associate Dean of
the Graduate School of Political Science,
Waseda University in Tokyo.
- We have Seiki Tanaka,
who will be possibly joining
us later this evening.
- Hi, I'm Mike Thies.
I'm at UCLA in the
political science department
and chair of global studies.
- Hi, I'm Mike Tomz.
I'm a professor of political
science at Stanford.
I'm also the chair of the
political science department
and a senior fellow at
the Stanford Institute
for Economic Policy Research.
Looking forward to having this
conversation with you today.
- Hi, I'm Hikaru Yamagishi.
I'm a PhD candidate at Yale.
Thank you.
- Thanks everyone, so first up,
we have a paper on which I'm a coauthor
of a really great team,
including a fantastic group
of PhD students from Yale;
Changwook Ju, Colin
Moreshead, Hikaru Yamagishi,
and Trevor Incerti,
as well as Frances
Rosenbluth, also of Yale,
and Seiki Tanaka at the
University of Groningen.
And so, presenting our
paper will be Changwook Ju,
Colin Moreshead and Hikaru Yamagishi.
So, without further ado, Hikaru,
please take it away.
- All right.
So today we're presenting our paper on
"The Logic of Soft Power Competition
"with Survey Evidence from Asia."
We'd like to give our great thanks
to the consulate general
of Japan in Boston
for generous funding for our research,
providing us an opportunity
to study questions
of great theoretical
and practical importance
and of our personal and
professional interests.
Thank you very much.
So the historical backdrop
of our inquiry are
two East Asian countries
vying for regional dominance.
Japan's preeminence as the
regions exporter has waned
a little since its
post-World War II heyday,
but observers note that Japan is building
its coffers of another product:
it's "gross national
coolness," we'll call it.
In his long reign in office,
former Prime Minister Abe
made a "Cool Japan" program
a multi-ministry effort coordinated
by the cabinet office
with specific goals like
increasing trade and tourism,
product purchases,
attracting foreign public opinion
for foreign policy and so on.
And we picked this picture
as perhaps an emblematic moment
at the 2016 Rio Summer
Olympics closing ceremony,
the handover ceremony,
where there was a video montage
with Japanese athletes,
Hello Kitty,
classic manga characters
and Prime Minister Abe
stuck in Tokyo traffic
in the beginning saying
he won't make it to Rio on time,
but with the help of Super Mario,
the video game, and his friends,
he teleports through a pipe and pops up
in the middle of the
stadium at Rio as Mario.
A viral moment, but for us,
the point being that, even
the softer side of soft power,
animation, cuisine,
it's not just bottom up
and political leaders
are actively harnessing
these resources for promotion and policy
for national gains.
And Chinese leaders have thrown their hats
in the ring as well.
Here are some quotes
from former President Hu;
"We must enhance culture
as part of soft power."
And President Xi;
"The vision is that Chinese
cultural soft power has grown
"much stronger."
So this is in the CCP Congress sessions.
So with the aim of winning
this public opinion war,
the Chinese Communist
Party sees increasing
the country's soft power
as a core national goal,
and has spent lavishly on efforts
like the Belt and Road Initiative as well.
So in this new era of
soft power competition,
our question is,
does soft power influence
global attitudes?
What soft power resources work
and under what conditions?
So right now, I'm spending
a quick three slides
on an overview,
and then I'll go a little
deeper into the theory ,
and then Colin and Chang will takeover
for case selection and design,
and I'll do some closing remarks.
So there's robust literature
on soft power in political science.
And building on Nye,
we structure our theoretical framework
with three key soft power resources.
So the first is culture;
things like art and drama.
The second one is political values,
such as freedom of speech
and a responsible government,
bill of rights and so forth.
And finally, foreign policy.
Another country's official
international relations policy
with one's home country.
So with this framework,
our main theory is as old...
The insight is practically as old
as the concept of soft power itself
but it's that domestic
political context matters.
So more specifically,
when the bilateral
relations are depoliticized
in the domestic political arena,
soft power efforts can work.
But when bilateral
relations are politicized
in domestic politics,
they can backfire.
Excuse me.
There we go.
Our main result...
Rather, sorry.
Our research design.
So we use a survey experiment setup
and we expose the audience to
soft power promotion efforts
by China and Japan in two key cases.
So South Korea first,
where the South Korea relationship...
Oh sorry, South Korea-Japan relationship
and the South Korea-China
relationship are politicized
in domestic politics.
And Malaysia, where the
Malaysia-Japan relationship
and the Malaysia-China relationship are
relatively depoliticized.
Our key results are that
soft power can be effective
in non-politicized environments
but backfires in politicized environments.
So we find that in Malaysia,
soft power efforts succeeded
in changing cooperative attitudes towards
each of the countries
promoting soft power,
but in South Korea, they backfired.
Our second point is that content matters.
Soft power research has showed
similar patterns of
effectiveness across contexts.
So for instance, foreign aid
and culture were more effective
in moving respondents willingness
to cooperate favorably,
whereas treatments showing
political values were
less effective.
And we'll discuss this later,
whether it was because of our setup
or because of various factors,
we'll talk about later.
The theoretical payoffs of our paper.
We theorize and test soft powers effects
across these three core
soft power resources.
We show how aid influence attitudes
in non-recipient countries
and we contribute to the
literature on public diplomacy.
So diving in further into our theory.
So there are three types
of soft power resources.
The first one is culture,
so these are things such as art,
literature, various cuisine and so forth,
that increases the attractiveness
of a country's profile
to the recipient individual.
This is an image of Pokemon characters
and Son-Goku animation
character from Japan
at the Macy's Thanksgiving day parade.
Foreign policy, theoretically,
is a host of different policy initiatives.
In our study today, we
focus on international aid.
This is a picture of ODA
being delivered from Japan.
And political values,
so this has been long
established in the literature,
originally by Nye and others,
as emblematic from the US'
robust democratic liberalism.
This picture is from the 1960s
US-Japan security protests
in Japan.
So that's the diet building
and that's all those people protesting.
So our theory from the individual level.
So on the right, here is kind
of the original environment
in which an individual is operating.
So this is a low politicization country,
say it's country X.
And this is a treatment,
a dosage of any soft power resource.
So let's say this is Japan...
Let's say this is a documentary
on Japanese beverage making
and its origins of whiskey, for instance.
And when the environment
is low politicized...
Not as politicized to begin with,
it's more or less a blank slate
or less politicized slate.
So the individual sees this, is exposed,
they have updates about their beliefs
about the foreign nation
and its trustworthiness and coolness,
and we hypothesized that
it increases support
for security and/or
economic relationships.
So next time they're out
for a gift for a friend,
they might look for a Japanese whiskey
rather than something else.
On the other hand,
this is another country,
Country Y in a highly
politicized environment.
And again, they might get exposure
to a soft power resource.
But in this case,
the mechanism is a little bit different
because they already have
priors about the country.
And what happens is rather
than updating information,
it's more of a prime
that associates back to their already held
negative emotional reactions,
which lead to less support
for security and economic relationships.
So now, a note for this slide is that
it's not necessarily that
a priming is going to lead
to less cooperative behavior
in terms of the bilateral relationship,
it's that empirically, we find that...
The literature finds and
we work within a framework
where more countries, when they politicize
a bilateral relationship,
it's more antagonistic
and in a negative sense than
a positive one, unfortunately.
And so, that's why when they get primed
about a politicized relationship,
the result is negative.
It's not necessarily about
having the prime or not itself.
All right, so moving on
to case selection, Colin.
- Okay, so with full understanding
that this panel is awash
with experts on the region,
I'm going to hazard an introduction
of our soft power senders.
These are the two countries really vying
for influence through soft power
in East Asia and abroad.
So they have a fairly
distinct characteristics.
I think everybody here
is probably familiar
with Japan has relatively successful,
soft cultural power,
and its economic success
is very well known.
Japanese government has spent quite a lot
on developmental assistance
and foreign aid programs
throughout the post-war era.
Chinese cultural power
has considerable reach,
depending on the content type and market,
and the government emphasis
on this is increasing.
Additionally China's growth rate
over the past few decades has gotten it
the sort of attention, I think,
that Japan received for
the economic miracle.
And recently, we've seen huge,
highly publicized developments,
like the One Belt One Road Initiative,
which are sort of meant to
showcase Chinese assistance
within a broader foreign policy framework.
So now we'll quickly run
through the dyads of our cases.
So up top, I should note
that there's not really
a perfectly politicized
or de-politicized case
to do this experiment.
We made our assessments on
which countries might work best
as cases from the background
on the theoretical dimensions
and survey data from over the years
about favoribility toward Japan and China,
and we'll see more on that data shortly.
But first up, the Japan-South
Korea relationship has been
pretty fraught for a very long time.
So despite a shared status
as developed democracies,
we see highly politicized
bilateral relations
because of historical factors
like wars, colonial legacy,
and more current pressing issues,
like security cooperation
and territorial disputes.
South Korea is not really a recipient
of Japanese aid
and Japanese cultural goods are
often targeted in South Korean boycotts.
Malaysia, in this case, is non-politicized
with Japan since bilateral
relations don't really feature
in domestic politics of Malaysia.
So the Malaysians are
consumers of Japanese products.
They've also received considerable funding
and technical assistance from Japan,
since the 1960s.
Moving onto the China side,
we see, I think, a different sort of case
with the China-South Korea relationship.
It's politicized for
very different reasons.
The primary clash here
between these countries is
over political issues and security issues.
And so, we've seen disputes
over human rights issues,
mischaracterizations of
the South Korean government's positions,
and the Chinese relationship
with North Korea can also cause issues.
So again, South Korea is
not really a recipient
of Chinese aid, of course.
And although, South Koreans
do consume Chinese goods
and cultural products,
I think that's the extent
of the relationship there.
Malaysia, once again, has little
or no politicization on
relations with China.
So it's a recipient of loans,
as part of BRI.
We have seen a willingness to be selective
about which projects the
Malaysian government wants
to accept as part of
the One Belt One Road Initiative.
There's also a large ethnic
Chinese minority in Malaysia
but the domestic racial cleavages haven't
really spilled over into
the bilateral relations with China.
So moving on, I think we
have a two-by-two here
that lays out, in the
simplest terms I think,
what our expectations should be based
on the assessments of these
dyads politicization levels.
So the Japan-South Korea
relationship is highly politicized,
which suggests that we would
have a backlash effect.
In the China-South Korea dyad,
we see relatively less politicization
but it still exists,
and so there's perhaps an opportunity
for within case variation among
the South Korea respondents
versus the Japan case.
Malaysia-Japan isn't politicized,
so we should hopefully see
some positive effects from treatments.
And the same goes for Malaysia-China.
So all in all, I think you can see,
we expect to see soft power efforts
by both countries doing better in Malaysia
than in South Korea.
And then, we might expect
to see some variation
among the South Korea respondent groups.
Okay, so this is a feeling thermometer
that we took from our respondents
to visualize and justify
that set of expectations.
So what you're seeing here
on the Y-axis is number of respondents,
and the X axis is feelings
with 10 being most positive.
So what we have here
is like a density plot
of feelings towards the countries.
And as you can see, the
South Korean respondents are
really quite negative
about both Japan and China,
whereas the Malaysian respondents are
pretty much more positive
about both countries.
And now, we'll take a look at the surveys.
So we fielded two surveys,
one in South Korea and one in Malaysia.
Each survey was completed in
the primary local language,
so Korean and Malay respectively.
Our first wave went out early this month.
We just finished our
second wave this week,
which followed up with respondents
between five and seven
days after completion
of the first wave.
And our intent for that second wave is
really to interrogate whether
these treatment effects are sticky.
So the results didn't make it
into the paper because
of time considerations
but they will be going
into future iterations.
We hope you stay tuned.
So the surveys were
administered by Dynata,
which is an online market
research company operating
in both South Korea and Malaysia.
For sampling, we stratified age and gender
to best approximate the sample
to the broader populations
and as a result, the Malaysian
sample we got matches,
more or less, on both age and gender.
The South Korean sample matches on gender
and skews just ever so
slightly young compared
with the broader population.
And so, for all these
screenings gave us samples
of 2,740 in South Korea
and 2,716 in Malaysia.
So we have three soft
power treatment groups
and a control group in both countries.
So the three soft power
treatment groups are meant
to track the theoretical categories
of soft power,
so cultural products on
the culture dimension,
politics as operationalized by protest,
and foreign policy here is in
the form of foreign aid.
So our two soft power senders or diffusers
in East Asia being Japan and China,
we used video treatments
rather than a conventional vignettes.
And this was difficult,
finding comparable video treatments
between Japan and China
to comparable messaging,
was a challenge.
We think that using the
real video treatments
better approximates how people
in South Korea and Malaysia are going
to encounter soft power.
So these videos are drawn
from fictional media
and news clips from each country.
And we would love to have
our respondents watch
"My Neighbor Totoro" in its entirety
but unfortunately, time
and money are both limited,
so treatments are limited
to only a few minutes.
And we have, in total,
a three by two factorial
design with the control.
So ending up with seven groups in total.
Respondents were randomly assigned
to the groups and watched
at least 100 seconds
of the corresponding video treatment.
So to go into a little
more detail on that,
I will hand it over to Changwook.
- Oh, thanks Hikaru,
and thanks Colin.
Since our seminar participants didn't have
a chance to see the
actual treatment videos,
let me briefly describe them.
For the control video,
we featured nature and flowers,
which we think are unrelated to soft power
in Japan and China.
For Japanese cultural soft power,
we chose a popular Japanese anime,
entitled "My Neighbor Totoro."
For Japanese cultural soft power,
we chose a video showing
how Japanese citizens
demonstrate their grievances
toward their government,
especially towards Former
Prime Minister Abe.
For the Japanese foreign aid treatment,
we chose a video of MOFA
promoting Japanese contribution
to nation-building projects
in developing countries.
The video focuses on foreign aid
for countries other than
South Korea and Malaysia.
So it suggests the general foreign policy,
not the direct payment or
benefit to the target countries.
Moving on to Chinese soft power treatment,
for comparability issue,
the premier selections
for Chinese soft power
largely echoed the selections for
the Japanese soft power.
With same control video,
we use another media clip from
a popular Chinese historical drama,
entitled "The Longest Day in China."
For Chinese political soft power.
We chose a video clip showing people
in Hong Kong protesting against
the Chinese government.
For the Chinese point aid treatment,
we employed a Chinese state
media promotional video
on the Belt and Road Initiative.
All the treatment videos are translated
and sub-titled according
to the (indistinct)
respective languages,
i.e. Korean and Malay.
Moving on to the key outcomes.
We focused on three domains
of international relations
and political economy.
Our economic consumption variable,
we asked respondents
whether they preferred to
purchase Chinese or Japanese
electronic products.
Respondents were given a choice
between a Chinese brand
and a Japanese brand
for three product lines;
smartphone, TV and home appliance.
Its brand was randomly drawn
from the listed brands here on the screen,
and respondents were asked to indicate
whether they prefer one or the other
on the 100 point probability scale.
We randomized the pair and
the ordering of brands,
and also the order of the
three electronic items.
We later rescaled the responses,
so the 100% represent a purchase
of the Chinese brand
over the competing Japanese brand.
But our two cooperation questions,
We asked the respondents whether
they think Korea or
Malaysia should cooperate
more with Japan and China
on trade, war, security matters.
The responses were measured
on a seven point Likert scale,
running from "strongly agree"
to "strongly disagree."
And moving on to kind of mechanism tests.
In addition to the key outcomes
that we just rendered,
we also measured potential outcomes...
Sorry, potential mechanisms.
First, we asked respondents how cool
they think Japan and China is.
The responses on this
statement were measured
on a five point scale.
And second, we provided them
with an 11 point scale
where they indicate their emotions
toward Japan and China, respectively.
Third, we gather three
types of generalized trust.
Be they a favorability
rating of Japan and China,
political trust for the Japanese
and Chinese governments,
and economic trust for Japanese
and Chinese product,
all of each who are
measured on 100 point scale.
Our estimation strategy is
the difference-in-means,
and it's been reported that
pandemic replication surveys are
comparable to pre-pandemic surveys
but with some smaller effect sizes.
Since our surveys were
conducted during COVID-19,
the estimates of our
(indistinct) effects may be
somewhat conservative.
As part of the main result,
the number one take away is that
soft power promotion can backfire
if the bilateral
relations are politicized.
To support this figure,
we combined all outcome variables
into a single dimensional index
for each soft power sender.
And we also conflated
all Japanese or Chinese
treatments for each country.
We found a large backlash
against the Japanese soft
power message in South Korea,
while the Chinese power message featured
a positive impact in Malaysia.
And then, we examine the effect
of each treatment on all
the major outcome questions,
using the same same strategy
to aggregate the questions.
Here, we observed some
hierarchical structure
of soft power sources.
For example, in Malaysia,
advertising foreign aid
significantly moves respondents' attitudes
in a positive direction.
And it seems cultural
promoting efforts can
also payoff in Malaysia.
However, media exposure
to protest is found
to have no effect
or elicit a significant backlash
for the Japanese treatment.
In South Korea, we found a backlash
against all Japanese soft power treatments
and the Chinese protest treatment.
We think that the protest may have caused
some respondents to
update their prior beliefs
about the the trustworthiness
of the Japanese government.
Moving on, we also
investigated the mechanisms
in which our treatments moved
respondent's perceptions
about the soft power senders.
The most notable pattern here is that
all treatments cause strong
negative emotional reactions
among South Korea respondents
vis-a-vis Japan and China.
In Malaysia, we observed
strong negative reactions
to both Japanese and Chinese protest,
while the Japanese
cultural treatment induced
some positive impact.
Interestingly, we observed
the positive impact
of Chinese aid
and the negative impact
of Japanese protests on
Malaysian respondent's perception
about the two soft power
senders trustworthiness
and cool Japan or cool China.
We can interpret this in line
with our finding in the paper,
that the Chinese aid to video works
for Malaysian respondents
on security and trade cooperation,
and another finding that
Japanese protest video backfires,
making Malaysian
respondents dislike security
and trade cooperation with Japan.
So in sum, emotion seems to drive
the backlash we observe
in a politicized setting,
like in South Korea,
and generalized trust and coolness matter
for security and trade cooperation
in a depoliticized setting,
like in Malaysia.
With that, over to you, Hikaru.
- Great, so for future research,
there's two avenues that
we'd like to highlight.
First, one of the three
soft power resources,
political values.
So we found that we would
like to unpack this further.
Our hypothesis was that
the protests will show freedom,
but perhaps this was our
political science minds working
too readily.
The inherent kind of
paradox of a protest is
that when you show someone protesting
against the government,
that definitionally means
that the government is doing
something that's not matching the will
of certain people.
So it might look like a vision
of conflict and disorder.
One way to push forward is
to show a retrospective narrative of Rome
when citizens protested
and the government changed in response.
And there are also other dimensions
of political values to explore.
We might have been too
Western liberal democratic
in our conception of political values.
There are many other dimensions,
like economic performance,
democratic process,
popular responsiveness,
that can show attractive
institutional features
in different forms.
Secondly, we are left with a question
of long run effects of soft power.
We realize that our design is
a small amount of exposure,
although similar to government
public diplomacy efforts perhaps,
and we can't manipulate how much country
a soft power has at the baseline.
We can try to understand long run change
in soft power, however,
using panel surveys and
field experiments over time.
And some examples,
such as an encouragement
design in the field.
We could have people subscribed
to one year subscriptions
of randomly Chinese
or Japanese media, for instance,
and see how the slowly changes
their long-term perceptions and so on.
In summary, in this paper,
we propose a logic of
soft power competition
and test it through survey experiments.
We hypothesize that the efficacy
of soft power is limited
by the politicization of relations
between the sender and target countries.
We find that domestic politics does shape
soft power effects.
When the bilateral
relationships are politicized,
soft power efforts can backfire.
And within soft power resources,
foreign aid is an easy avenue
to willing hearts and minds.
And so, we find that content matters.
And we also, for next steps,
find that more research
on this more institutional
and more nuanced political
values dimension is needed.
Thank you very much.
- Great, thank you.
Thanks so much to this great team
that I'm a member of
for this great presentation.
Now, we have a set of discussion starters
to get the conversation rolling.
And please also feel free to continue
to use the chat function.
And for attendees,
you're also welcome to use
the Q&A function as well.
So first up, we have Professor
Joe Nye from Harvard,
giving us comments on this paper.
Thank you.
- Well, I read this
paper with great interest
and regard it as a important
contribution empirically,
which has advanced how we think
about soft power.
By using these video
clips and survey research,
you provided empirical evidence
from certain things that I had stated
in general terms
but never proven.
I've often said that soft
power is distinguished
from other types of power in the sense
that it depends on the
eye of the beholder.
And I sometimes use the anecdote,
or a little example,
that if I want to steal
your money with hard power,
I pull out a gun, shoot you
and take your wallet.
It doesn't matter what you think.
But if I wanted to steal your money
by convincing you I'm a guru
and that you should give it to me,
it all depends on what you think.
And so, essentially what
this paper has done is taken
that question and said, "All right.
"How do we see how people think
"and how does it vary
with the different types
"of soft power resources
"in the different contexts?"
So I think it's an important paper,
which advances (indistinct)
for something which previously was made
without any evidence.
I should say that the...
I'll tell you,
this question of which
types of resources have
which types of effects are intriguing.
I'll give you a brief anecdote
to illustrate this related to China.
I was asked to give a lecture
on soft power at the School of
Marxism at Peking University,
in China over a half dozen years.
And after I spoke to an audience
of 1,500 students and the
Dean had introduced me,
everything was going swimmingly,
except I said something about Ai Weiwei,
and also about Liu Xiaobo.
And at the end, when the Dean came up
from the platform, again, to thank me,
he said, "Oh, it's so great
that Professor Nye has come
"and spoken to us."
And then my interpreter
stopped interpreting,
and he kept talking
and then, eventually,
it ended up with his
thanking me again profusely.
And later, I asked a friend of mine,
who is Mandarin speaking
who was in the audience,
"What was that all about?"
He said, "What he did
was tell the students
"that Professor Nye may
have been the person
"who coined the term "soft power,"
"but he treated it too
much in political terms
"and not enough in cultural terms.
"And here in China,
"we think of it as culture, not politics."
So that's an anecdotal illustration
of the difference between
the three types of resources
and how it works out politically.
I think the interesting question for me,
you've now demonstrated that
priors matter empirically,
but I think it would
be interesting to know,
what are the different sources
of domestic politicization?
And if you're trying to
translate this to policy,
what are the things that a country can do
in its public diplomacy,
given the politicization
that may or may not occur
in another country?
For example, how much of the
domestic politicization is
because of leaders,
which the paper refers to,
leaders politicizing it?
But sometimes, it may be, in fact,
historical and structural.
I mean, the Korean
attitudes to Japan persisted
right through a conservative
Korean government
and a liberal or progressive
Korean government.
And they're now bedeviling the efforts
with the Americans are making
to try to get Korea and Japan
to cooperate on the issue of
sharing intelligence relating
to North Korea.
So China, in other words,
it may be that the politicization
in some cases is
historical and structural.
And then, the interesting question is,
to what extent, if the Japanese
government, for example,
wants to exercise public diplomacy
and to use its soft power,
what can it do?
And I didn't get an answer to that
from the paper.
I did get an answer of how it varied
by the different resources,
but I didn't actually...
It'd be nice to have another twist
of the screw on this,
one step further, to know,
all right, what could that mean
for actual practitioners
of public diplomacy?
There are...
Also, it would be interesting
to know something about time series.
I mean, this is churlish to complain
that you don't have time series,
but it would be interesting to know
what happens when events occur
and what happens over time?
How do these variables change?
I noticed that you quoted
Naima Green-Riley's
very good thesis on soft power,
showing that American
students who had taken courses
through Confucius Institute
were not more pro-Chinese,
but less so.
It'd be interesting to know
if one were to look...
I don't know, Naima,
whether you have the data
on this or not.
It'd be interesting to know
whether that would have
been true, let's say,
six or seven years ago
before you had the turn in the attitude
of Americans relating to China or not.
But no, I think, if for
future empirical studies,
if we could get more time series,
that would help a lot.
And there's also, finally,
the question of what
policies governments make
which can bring on the
backlash that you described.
I'm struck, having recently been involved
in discussions with Indians,
who the aftermath of the
recent meeting of this Quad
that occurred a couple of weeks ago,
Indian said that it was intriguing that
when China started exercising
its Wolf-Warrior diplomacy,
which was obviously based on
domestic opinion in China,
it was for domestic consumption,
that had a terrible effect in India.
Not only the killing of Indian troops
on the border,
but the aftermath of that,
in which you had Chinese nationalism
stimulating Indian nationalist responses,
which led, incidentally, to the banning
of Tik Tok in India.
So it'd be interesting to know,
are there certain steps
that governments take
which can damage or severely
damage it's soft power
in another country in
which that can be avoided?
Still, I love the paper.
I thought it was great to have
this empirical research.
But it just made me thirst for more.
More on time series,
more at a wider of countries.
But anyway, as a major contribution
to getting empirical research
upon the effects of soft power,
my congratulations to the to the authors,
all seven of them.
- Thank you, thank you
so much, Professor Nye.
(indistinct) I call for more
more research on this important topic
among other things.
Next, we have Professor Maria Repnikova.
Maria--
- Yes, can you hear me?
Great.
Thank you so much for the invitation.
I also really enjoyed the paper.
I think it's very rich empirically
but I also found a lot of
interesting theoretical insights.
For me, one of the big takeaways was
also the breakdown of the
democratic-authoritarian binary
and analyzing the effects of soft power,
which I think has been overshadowing
much of the analysis of soft power,
especially when it comes to China.
This idea that because China
is an autocratic country,
its efforts are dismissed preemptively,
or at least considered to be ineffective,
and I think your paper shows that
the fact that China is an
autocratic country doesn't
necessarily make it ineffective
or a failure.
And in fact, because Japan
is a democratic country,
it doesn't necessarily make it a success.
So there's kind of this
interesting complication
of the democracy-autocracy binary
in thinking about soft power.
I think you could highlight that even more
in your theoretical contributions.
My comments, some of them also
echo Professor Nye's comment
about the concept of depoliticization,
how to think about this further.
So there are several
points I wanted to make.
The first one is that
depoliticization, to me,
echoing this idea of time series,
it appears to be a very dynamic concept.
So it challenges its operationalization.
How do we know for sure
when the relationship is politicized
versus depoliticized?
For example, in 2018,
the Malaysian PM publicly canceled
a major Chinese infrastructure project,
creating a rupture in the relationship
but then a year later.
he takes a U-turn in resuming
the relationship with China.
So how does this concept
that comes with such dynamic shifts
and what specific forms
of behavior over time
amount to this idea of
politicization of ties?
So how do we know when
they're politicized enough
or not enough?
I think it's a very fluid concept in a way
and it quickly changes,
so maybe it's about watching it
or observing it over time,
or maybe it's about adding
more alternative variables
or sub-variables that
would help us explain
or understand this concept.
The second point in
relation to this concept,
I think, this echoes this idea of
this notion that politicization
comes from leaders.
The way you define it is very top down.
Basically, the government defines
or forms or shapes the
opinions of the society
when it comes to these various countries.
But in reality, seems
that this relationship is
often quite interactive, right?
The society itself often pushes
the government to frame or
implement certain policies
that are much more politicized.
And we see this, of course,
in the US vis-a-vis China.
I think it's also notable
in the cases you study.
But also, in many other contexts,
it seems that the public opinion
actually shapes this
politicization efforts
from the top.
And then, moreover, we also can see that
at times, politicization
of societal attitudes is
not the same thing
or in contradiction to official policies.
So I see this a lot in
my research in Africa
where, with regards to China,
we see often very
"depoliticized" sort of attitudes
from the state
but very politicized attitudes
on a societal level,
where the public is very critical of China
and has preconceived views about China,
based on its economic presence,
but also various rumors and assumptions
about its corrupt practices, interference,
Chinese community taking
over and so forth.
So in a sense, there's
these predetermined views
that can coexist with
official depoliticization.
So I think those two can be contradictory.
So there's more, I think,
to think about there,
of how you think about this concept?
Top-down versus bottom-up.
Interactive, contradictory,
it's a very interesting idea.
And thirdly, I think depoliticization
almost presumes, in your idea,
in your paper, neutrality.
The lack of negative framing.
But in reality, politicization
in the other direction is also,
I think, quite significant.
The pro-China narratives
or pro-Japan narratives.
In the case of Malaysia, for instance,
there's been so much politicization
in the case of pro-China
attitudes, in recent years,
through various state media articles.
Just a quick search,
I found so many articles that are
very positive about China
in Malaysian press.
That, to me, signals that there is
the other direction of politicization,
which one could call propaganda,
persuasion and so forth.
So how does that play into this picture?
Should we look at politicization
from the other side as well?
In addition to this thinking
about politicization,
there are a couple of other
points I wanted to make.
The first one is about
practices of soft power.
So you talk a lot about the effects
but when it comes to
practices, for instance,
are there any major distinctions
in how China and Japan
practice soft power?
You mentioned the resources
but do they enact it differently?
In one part of your paper,
you note how Japan practices foreign aid
more through small scale projects,
as opposed to large scale, visible,
or what some school is referred
to as "prestige projects,"
that are implemented by China.
Another notable difference might be
there's more state-directed way
of soft power implementation in China
versus more kind of bottom
up implementation from Japan.
And now, there might be the emphasis
of the key offerings of soft power,
which I guess is hard to
capture in this paper.
But in my research,
I find that China's
approach to soft power is
distinctively pragmatic, for instance.
Much less so ideational.
And precisely because of
its pragmatic approach,
to prioritize access
and material benefits,
it appears to be relatively well received
in parts of Global South.
So what are the distinctions
between, I think, Japan
in this case and China,
when it comes to their practices
and their offerings,
not only when it comes to effects?
I think that will be very interesting
to at least mention
somewhere in the paper.
And I think, finally,
while it's impossible
to, I guess, address any or all
possible alternative factors or forces
that could shape the attitudes
towards soft power,
in this context, it's important to
at least consider two complimentary,
I think, explanations.
One is economic;
both South Korea and Malaysia have
very strong trade relations with China
but less so with Japan,
so there's an economic
kind of dimension there.
But also, Malaysia clearly has a much
stronger dependency on China with the BRI,
so how does this economic factor feature
into politicization or the attitudes
vis-a-vis China and Japan?
And another complimentary
factor is cultural proximity.
You mentioned the diasporic factor briefly
but according to some estimates,
there's almost 23% of ethnic
Chinese living in Malaysia,
so how does this shape the
potential views on China
and responses to soft power,
especially because one
of China's soft power,
and what some also described
as "sharp power," strategies is
to target Chinese communities overseas.
So, at the very least,
some of these people
might be also answering
your questions in a survey
because it's a very high percentage.
I think that would be very interesting.
And the last point that just came up to me
after listening to the presentation is
this idea of clarifying or complicating
the notion of political values.
I would strongly suggest that
because notion of protest and
especially anti-Hong Kong...
Oh sorry, Hong Kong
anti-government protest is
very...
I mean, it's an automatically
negative depiction of China.
But, of course, if you think
about China's political values,
at least from my analysis
of the training materials
when they train elites,
it's mostly about meritocracy,
state capacity and accountability.
So that that's what they advertise.
So maybe adding something
from their perspective would be useful to,
again, de-Westernize
this idea of soft power.
Thank you so much.
- Great, thanks so much,
Professor Repnikova.
Next, we have Professor Atshushi Tago.
- Yeah, let me share the screen
for the non-native English speaker,
being (indistinct) discussing afterwards
of the (indistinct) scholars
is the toughest job.
And let me screen share what
I have think about the paper.
So highly commendable points
of the paper and the project.
I assume that it's not
the only outcome of this
large public project.
So attention and new evidence
on the backfire is quite interesting.
I think it's very a good way
to direct the research.
An experiment in Malaysia,
I think it's a relatively new
and also commendable point.
And then, more specifically,
I would like to hear,
because I know you guys
have done the second wave,
the long-term effect,
from Professors Joseph Nye's comment,
it have to be probably
over year, over months,
but still, as the experiment scholar
who have been working
on the public diplomacy,
a week old panel is also
kind of commendable.
So one of the hardest challenge
for scientific public diplomacy,
or (indistinct) scholars,
how long the effect of the
information continue is
one of the key, probably the challenge.
And you guys are doing that
and I commend that.
By the way, they already
nicely decided my work,
so I shouldn't be greedy on that
but I have another
project that I used video,
and by the way, it's a course at work
by Testuro Kobayashi of
the University of City...
City University of Hong Kong.
It's 38 seconds above the 38th parallel,
so it's about the Korea and Japan
and it's US military-made video.
I guess it can be somehow related
to what you're doing
but given that, I know how
tough to do the video type
of the experiment.
And that may be one of the critical point
that I would raise.
So I enjoyed reading the paper
but I have some couples questions
and suggestions.
I saw that the first,
that the three pillars,
I know many of the disc...
I mean, the panelists already raise
their concerns or their
questions regarding that point
but so, I make my statement very briefly.
I think your manuscript
can be much stronger
to defend why those three are key
and why we really have to focus on those.
And second, why two countries?
Obviously, many people would
come up with this question
but I think you need to mention,
for instance, a status or role
of the media in each country
because the public diplomacy soft power.
I mean, media definitely plays
a significant role there.
And I'm curious, how the authors evaluate
the role of media in public diplomacy
or soft power in general,
and in your study?
I saw that you didn't
mention anything on that
so somehow, I'm very curious.
And most important, when you use a video,
there is a pro and con.
For the negative people
I faced with my papers (indistinct),
they were relatively nice.
Still, but they raised the question,
like what were they really watching
and what information had been given
or have been received,
or more precisely, manipulated?
I think that one is probably
toughest question to you.
Five,
I wonder, was it in that competing setting
of the public diplomacy information,
history issues or a peaceful country image
of China and Japan?
I might do that.
So if you have the
continuation of the project,
you can probably try that in the future
or at least you have to probably defend
in a footnote or something that,
why those threes are the...
By design or empirical reasons,
I don't know what would be the rationale,
but you probably defend yourself there.
For the sixth point,
I think pretreated long-term effect is
quite different from Korea and Malaysia.
I assumed that more exposure
to the Japanese manga in the ROK.
So for their negative or now results
for the (indistinct) on the "Totoro,"
because they already watched them
repeatedly or too much.
And so, I don't know.
I guess the pre-treated long-term effect,
how do you evaluate?
How to do think about that?
And that'll be the question.
And finally, I really enjoyed the project
but I feel puzzling on this point.
So what would be the
solutions for the backfire?
So for the Japanese government,
I think public diplomacy is have been done
in order not to politicize
the image of Japan.
So by design, it's very
puzzling paper for me.
And if you, at least, mention
about the potential solutions
for the backfire,
it will probably break
and it would be much more
significant contribution
in the public diplomacy studies.
And that's it.
So I'll turn the floor to the...
- Great, thank you so much, Professor Tago
for those comments.
So we have one more discussion with
with brief comments, Professor Kobayashi.
Professor Kobayashi is
actually going to be
a sort of switch hitter today,
and because of the communication staff,
we provided comments for both papers,
but brief comments.
And while Professor Kobayashi is talking,
please feel free to use
the raise hand feature
if you want to jump in on the discussion,
and I will get to you
after we go first to Professor Kobayashi.
- Thank you.
The reality is I was completely confused
and I read the wrong paper.
So I am assigned to the second paper
but I realize that I read the first paper.
So I'm going to split my discussion time
into half and half
and I'm going to spend
2.5 minutes for each.
So let me rush for my comments
for the first paper.
I learned a lot from this paper
and thank you very much,
it's so interesting.
Although, I'm not an expert of soft power
'cause I study public opinion
in East Asian countries,
it's so much interesting
and it's a really kind of imminent issue.
Especially, when I'm living in Hong Kong
and see a lot of hard and
soft power from China.
So I would like to raise
only one theoretical question
and two methodological questions.
One is about...
Although, already many
people have pointed out,
I had a question,
is foreign aid really
a part of soft power?
So in the case of China's
foreign aid, for instance,
they are always suspicions
of so-called debt trap.
And there's also an alleged motive
behind it to secure supporting voices
in the United Nations, for instance.
And so, the more recent
cases, for instance,
the vaccine diplomacy,
so-called "vaccine diplomacy,"
it's part of foreign aid.
But for instance, Paraguay
was asked by China
to cut off diplomatic
relations with Taiwan
in exchange for providing the vaccine,
so obviously there are
some kind of overlap
between these kind of seemingly soft power
and different strategies
and the hard part,
which basically coerce some
specific type of actions
of the recipient of this aid.
So that's my theoretical question.
The two methodological questions concerns
experimental stimuli.
So the design of experiments is
very much interesting,
but if I take a closer
look into the treatments,
for instance, in the Japanese
foreign aid treatment,
it includes its support for the POSCO
in South Korea,
which is actually a very
sensitive issue in South Korea.
With regard to the the
Japanese financial aid
and its recipient in South Korea
after 1965 treaty,
it is not difficult to imagine
that some South Korean
participants are offended
by this reference to POSCO, for instance.
The Chinese foreign aid treatment
also includes its support
for Malaysian sea freight.
So these kinds of bilateral foreign aid is
actually included in these stimuli,
and that would have some
kind of specific effects,
depending on the context of
these bilateral relations.
The last point is about
the Hong Kong protest.
So I actually didn't understand
why Hong Kong protest signifies
the political value of China.
Because the reason protests
in Hong Kong are labeled
as a pro-independence movement
by the Chinese central government,
the government initially censored
the protest related to
information in the mainland
and afterward, it severely
attacked the movement.
So therefore, the Hong Kong protests have
never been something that China would
like to sell to the world.
More of a harsh clamp down
of the protest invoked a lot
of international criticism.
So I think the political value
that China wants to sell is stability
instead of this kind of,
"Hey, we also accept protests,
"we are also free society,"
that kind of things.
So I guess it might be
a worthwhile elaborating
more of the value is that,
what kind of values that each
country would like to sell.
So in the case of Japan,
it might be like kind of Article Nine,
rather than just showing
the anti-government protest.
So that will be more general
and fundamental value
that Japan has something
to sell to the world.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to send up the other comments
to the authors later.
- Great, thank you so
much, Professor Kobayashi.
I really...
And to Professors Tago, Repnikova and Nye,
for those really fantastic comments.
And all of these points
are very well taken.
I'm however, I'm gonna...
As hard as it is as a moderator,
I'm going to muzzle myself
because we have a great group of people
with their hands raised.
And so, with the permission
my other team mates,
who are free to jump in,
I want to just keep
going with the questions
and maybe at the end,
we'll have a minute or two
where we can respond little bit,
but mostly, at this point,
I'd love to listen.
So first on the list, we have Mike Tomz.
- Hi everyone.
I really enjoyed reading this paper
and I'm grateful for the opportunity
to listen to the presentation
and to the discussion so far.
You've already been asking questions
about the details of the
treatments and the data.
I wanted to ask two big picture questions
about the punchline of the paper,
one is theoretical
and the other is practical.
So at a theoretical level,
one way, I think, to read this paper is
to say that the paper's claiming
that attempts to promote
soft power will fail
if the intended audiences are hostile
to the message.
Or if you want to flip that around,
another way of saying is
that countries are more
likely to be successful
at promoting soft power
when they're preaching to the choir
than when they're not.
So I wanted...
So my first question is,
whether at a theoretical level,
you think that that's a
fair reading of the paper
and if so, if you think
that that's a surprising
theoretical claim.
My second question is about
the practical implications
of your research
for policymakers.
So another big picture takeaway
or way to read this paper is
that efforts to promote soft power are
most likely to fail in dyads
where soft power might be most needed.
And if you think that
that's a fair reading,
do you think your findings
might be discouraging
to policymakers who want to use soft power
as a way to improve relations
in dyads that might not
otherwise be harmonious?
- Great, thank you.
Next, Professor Amy Catalinac.
- Yeah. I also really enjoyed the paper
and the presentation.
It's just fascinating.
So my comment is jumping off
something that Mike said.
So one of your conclusions, I think,
is that soft power,
it just doesn't work and
politicized environments
when the relationship between the sender
and the target is politicized.
So that suggests that if that's the case,
governments shouldn't be
directing soft power resources
to those countries.
And I wonder if a really nice compliment
to your experiment might be
to look at the composition of governments'
soft power resources.
Do we see a bias in
directing those resources
toward countries where
they are going to work?
and your theory would lead us
to expect that governments,
if they're smart,
should not be spending too much money
in politicized environments.
I just wonder if that's the case.
And also, just to echo what Mike said,
it is interesting to think about the fact
that that is sort of where
soft power should be most directed.
So it might help us advance the concept
of soft power to understand
when and why it's used.
And I'm in general, just a
fan of observational work,
especially when it
compliments experiments.
But thank you for the opportunity
to read the paper and
see the presentation.
- Great, thanks so much.
Next, we have Jennifer Lind
and Benjamin Goldsmith.
- Hi everyone.
Lovely to see everybody.
I hope you're all well.
I just had a couple of comments on
this really interesting paper.
So I don't work in the
soft power realm so much,
so I would love to see you frame it
by first establishing,
"soft power matters.
"Here's why.
"Here's the empirical support," right?
So point is to the studies
that show that this
actually has this effect.
Also to say, soft power
comes from many sources,
but one way that we know
that countries can get soft power is
through their policies.
And here's why we know this,
here's the empirical support and so on.
So again, it's establishing
that soft power is not just something
that a country is
or that relates to its
generalized foreign policy
but that you can...
I don't want to say by soft power
but that you can affect it
through government policies
to make your country seem more favorably.
So again, it would be soft power matters,
soft power comes from both
who you are and what you do,
but also through deliberate,
proactive efforts to cultivate it.
And then, the question
of your paper could be,
"Okay, so under what conditions will
"a country be more successful
"at cultivating it?"
And I think that that
brings you to your paper.
I had...
So again, there's so much to like here
and I had so many questions,
but one thing I'll just mention
that kind of stuck out
was, unsurprisingly,
on the issue of historical memory.
The paper creates these three categories
of culture, politics and foreign policy.
And you talk about if relations are bad
in the culture realm,
then they'll only be aggravated
by a government's efforts
to build soft power
in that realm.
And so, that made me wonder about
this culture category.
I guess I'm not sure about the connection
between Japanese anime and sushi,
and political apologies, right?
Which you kind of put it in that category.
And so, these things just seem
really different to me.
Again, the paper says that relations
between South Korea and
Japan are politicized
because of culture, historical grievances
and diplomatic conflicts,
and a lot of that sounds
like politics to me.
In fact, I think of the countries
as actually having really
good cultural relations.
K-pop and J-pop and all the things
that they share.
So again, it's mostly politics,
political apologies
and the territorial dispute
over Dokdo Takeshima,
that seemed to be the root of the problem.
So again, I was confused
about putting everything
into that culture bucket.
I had one reaction in terms of
at the end of the day, people could say,
"Okay, these are just
these single case studies."
You have one neutral, as
you called it, country,
you had one politicized country,
and maybe you've just taught us
something about Malaysia and Japan...
Oh sorry, Malaysia and Korea.
Is there something
simple that you could do
to bolster yourselves
against that kind of charge?
So maybe, obviously, not running
this whole thing again
and in these other countries
but like mechanical Turk
in some smaller study,
where you could just kick the tires of it?
And in other countries that...
Singapore and Philippines,
Australia, European countries
or something like that.
if there would be something simple
that you could do in three or four,
four or five other countries
that people would agree,
"Yeah, they're quite neutral."
And if you, you found actually
quite similar findings,
I think that would bolster
the credibility of your answer.
- Yeah, and I guess I'm next.
So just a couple of comments.
Yeah, thanks very much.
I also really, really liked the paper
and find it fascinating
in providing a lot of important insights.
A couple of comments.
One reflects a comment I have in the chat.
I especially like the focus on competition
in the theoretical
discussion and the framing.
But I also think that's
really underdeveloped
in the theory especially.
It's mentioned and the theory is presented
as a theory of soft power competition.
I would be pretty excited to see
a nicely developed theory, for example,
when two states intend to compete.
You mentioned China in the US
as the obvious example.
Think of Africa or South America,
and of course, Asia as well,
but Japan and China are clearly competing
and intend to compete, in my view,
in Asia in the soft power realm.
But as the theory...
As its spelled out in most parts
of this study are are bilateral
in the way they're set up.
And the second comment is about the
the role of culture.
So I think there's an issue with
the way culture is discussed.
I think it needs to be defined
much more clearly.
Anything from being cool
to different modes of
entertainment can fit in that box
and it's not clear, at least to me,
how that very diverse set of
factors might have an impact.
So those are my two comments.
I'll send you written comments as well
on the whole paper.
Thanks.
- Great, thank you.
Next, we've Phillip Lipscy
and then Michael Thies after that.
- Yeah, I really like this paper.
Thanks for the opportunity to read it.
So I had two comments.
I have a bunch more
but I'll just focus on two.
So, so one of them is similar
to what Atsushi was saying
in his discussing comments,
which is I felt like the paper might need
some kind of theory about how existing
public diplomacy efforts relate
to the methodology, right?
In other words, if Japan is very active
in public diplomacy efforts in a country,
is your treatment effect
going to be attenuated
because citizens are already
being aggressively primed
with the same kind of information?
And does the degree of public diplomacy
differ between Korea and
Malaysia, for example?
The assumption seems to be,
it's going to be the
same, there was no effect,
but is that really true?
I mean, the other possibility is that
through these existing efforts,
citizens would become more susceptible
to prime somehow,
so that might be another possibility.
But in either case,
I think some discussion
of that would be useful.
And the second point was,
my observation of the
public diplomacy strategy,
as it's occurring, seems
to be focused lately
on opinion leaders
and I've even heard influencers used
by some officials,
and sort of thinking about
that mechanism, right?
So if these messages are coming
from people you trust
within your own country,
does that make a difference
versus if it's obviously coming
from the source country?
Because that seems to be, at least,
from my very qualitative,
impressionistic sense,
where a lot of the attention is going
in the public diplomacy sphere these days.
It's let's focus on these people
who have a lot of Twitter followers
and try to change their mind.
So for future research,
that might be worth thinking about.
Thanks.
- Great, thank you.
Michael Thies is next.
- Ah, thanks.
Yeah, thank you for the
presentation going this late.
Some of the points I wanted to
make have already been made,
particularly by Jennifer and Ben.
So let me try to summarize what I see
as the source of some of these concerns,
and that is that while
you run the experiment
in the way you should
and you check for
balance within your cases
in all the right ways,
and you have enough
presumably enough power
to make the inferences you want to make
within the cases,
for the big points that
you're making in the paper,
what you really have
is an N of two, right?
You've got South Korea, Malaysia
and I guess two senders as well.
And a lot of the questions, I think,
come from the notion that
you acknowledged in the paper
that there are a lot of differences
between these countries
that may be confounding
at least your interpretations
of the results
that you're finding.
So one thing that struck me
on the aid treatment in particular is
that I just looked and, at
least according to the IMF,
South Korea now has a
higher per capita income
than Japan,
and much, much higher
than China, of course.
So aid, who knows how aid plays,
and particularly Japanese aid plays,
in the Korean sort of imagination?
Is it, is it envy?
Is it jealousy?
Is it resentment?
What's going on?
There's a lot there.
And then, South Korea
is smack in the middle
of Japan and China.
It's affected by hard
power in lots of ways.
It's different from
Malaysia in so many ways
that it's hard to isolate
the thing that's really
causing the difference.
Is it this politicization of
the bilateral relationship
or is it something else?
On the politicization,
I will echo the points made earlier,
that I think it would be useful for you,
at the very least in the conclusion,
to suggest more systematic ways
to measure politicization.
So I think you started
with these two cases,
Korean and Malaysia,
where you just figured
this is going to be uncontroversial.
Everyone's going to agree
that the relationships between Korea
and the two senders
are clearly politicized
and for Malaysia, there doesn't seem
to be any evidence of that.
It'd be nice.
It's always...
Professor Nye use the word "churlish."
It's always difficult to
comment on an experiment to say,
"Well, here's all the things
you should have done."
But to have (indistinct)
diagonal cases, right?
Where one of them had a
politicized relationship
with China but not with Japan
and the other vice versa,
if there are any such cases,
to get a little bit of leverage on that.
I also wanted to echo what Jennifer said
about the treatment of culture.
In Korea, to my understanding,
culture gets hijacked in the politics
of the relationship
between the two countries.
There are no particular
cultural disputes specifically
because culture and industry,
money are so related,
South Korean government
likes to use culture
as sort of a weapon
in it's political disputes with Japan.
So is the fraught nature
of their relationship,
the politicization of the relationship,
really about culture
or is cultures just being used there?
And so, is it really a good case
for finding the impact of
the cultural treatments
that you're looking for?
Again, to echo Professor Nye's point
about time series.
You do mention COVID
is as a potential issue
for doing this in February of '21,
but just to snapshot is going to be
a bit of an issue because diplomacy is
a continuous thing.
It waxes and wanes.
South Korean and Japan, for example,
or with China,
the relationship warms and it cools
and it warms and it cools.
And so, if the questions
happened to be asked
of people at a time when
the South Korean government is explicitly
or implicitly organizing a boycott
of Japanese cultural products,
you're gonna get a very different
set of answers, probably,
from your respondents
than if it's in a warmer period,
for whatever.
The last thing I wanted to say is,
and here, Jennifer really did anticipate
one of my suggestions,
which is for those of us
who are not already steeped
in the literature on soft power,
a slightly more rigorous summary
of that literature about why it matters
and about how it works
I think would be useful,
especially if you want to send this
to a general interest journal.
And how it works, what I mean by that is,
your measures looking at these surveys,
and I guess this could be said about
the other paper that
we'll discuss next too,
are looking at the impact
on public opinion, right?
Just the average citizen in the street.
What are their feelings about this country
in terms of trust or things like that?
How does that translate to the goals
that the sending country is
actually seeking to fulfill?
So how does a warm feeling about Japan
or about China make its way up
to your own government's relationship
with the sending country?
I'm sure this is in the literature already
in general terms.
but if you could summarize
that for the reader,
but then also think about
how you might get at that
in terms of your examination.
So this may be more of
an observational accompaniment
to the experiment.
But just as a comparativist
who doesn't study
international relations and soft power,
the "so what?" question really
was flashing over my head
as I was reading.
It's like, this is all
very interesting internally
within the experiment but...
Especially, when you were looking for
the longevity of these things
and you said you did a follow-up
a week later or something like that,
a couple of weeks later.
And I think in the other paper,
they showed results
that lasted three weeks
or something like that.
What's three weeks in a
diplomatic relationship?
How big a deal is this?
Some sense of that.
So I'm not necessarily
saying it's not a big deal
but sell it to the reader.
- Great, thank you.
And then finally, Sijeong Lim.
And maybe, Tae-Ho Kim, you also...
Okay.
- Thank you for sharing your
fascinating research with us.
I actually shared on many strong points
about the paper,
but I also share some of the concerns
about the treatments.
Whether the treatments are
actually manipulating the things
that the authors wanted to manipulate.
And on that point,
if you were to do a followup survey
or redesign the survey,
one thing I just wanted to suggest,
as also one of the South Korean audience
in the room,
was to make the treatment sharper
and, in doing so, also try
to make it more relational,
more directed,
and centering on the empathy.
So in this treatment
across all three issue areas,
the treatments were videos.
It doesn't have any particular target.
It doesn't at least mention the target
but I think what South Koreans
especially appreciate when it comes
to the relationship with Japan,
especially the ordinary
public in South Korea,
is how some of the
Japanese politicians are
actually thinking similarly with Koreans.
So maybe if there's
some of the treatments,
maybe not in terms of the video,
which is harder,
but in just traditional vignettes,
if somehow...
For instance, the political
value treatment mentions
how as democracy,
we, Japan are quite similar to Korea
in having this vibrant civil society,
and that's where you can make
the public diplomacy activity relational
and resort to empathy.
I think that's might be the key actually
in how the public diplomacy
should be conducted
in a more politicized
and a rivalry setting
because, in that way,
you can see how Japan is
also reaching out to us Koreans,
not just to to the broader audience
across the globe.
So I think...
I just wonder if the
more relational message,
more directed message,
have a different impact,
especially if the modular
impact could be greater
when under the conditions
of politicization.
Also, about the measuring of
the dependent variable.
I was wondering if you can take advantage
of the competition environment here
between Japan and Korea,
and whether you actually had a
both choice type of DV,
whether you will cooperate
more with China or Japan thing,
instead of just asking them one-by-one
and say, if this competition...
Even though there is a slight backlash,
maybe still, the recipient of
the public diplomacy will choose us
over the competitor.
So I just wanted to see how
this competition dynamic
might be incorporated
into the survey design,
especially in the East Asian context.
That's it for me.
- Great, thank you.
And last, Tae-Ho Kim.
- Thank you, I really
enjoyed good comments.
And just to try to add two small points;
one about case selection
and second one, a policy recommendation.
I think the motivation
to start this paper comes
from Japan-China regional rivalry.
Hard power rivalry between one US ally
and one competitor of US.
And then, you became curious
how these two countries
soft power works for Korea,
which means you picked up case
out of strong hard power,
and then try to relate soft power
to explain your hard power relationship.
But reality, South Korea is a
more strong soft power sender
to China and Japan
in K-pops and sports and cultures.
And China controls Korean soft power,
and Japan just a little bit to play
in domestic politics.
So I think you should think about
the influence of soft power of South Korea
to these great powers.
If you try to academically compare
the role of soft and hard power.
My second point is about the solution
that this paper is very strong
in the deductive logic.
The key is a politicization
in domestic politics.
But the problem is South
Korea's domestic politicization
on history issue.
Here, the key is,
who captured the power
in South Korean politics?
If you look at the past 20 years history,
whenever conservative, righty,
political camp captures Korean power,
Korea-Japan relations get ease
and much more co-operative
in security issues.
But like this time,
liberal and lefty
governments captures power,
all problems becomes politicized.
So this paper implies
Korean domestic politics,
which cannot be controlled
by Japan and China,
will decide the impact of hard power
and soft power relationship
between Japan and Korea...
Between Korea and China
and Korea and Japan.
Thank you very much.
- Great work.
Thank you to all of the panel participants
and especially to our discussants,
Professor Joe Nye,
professor Maria Repnikova,
Professor Atsushi Tago
and Professor Tetsuro Kobayashi
for those fantastic comments.
I'm again going to resist the urge
to give a lengthy response
to these great, great suggestions
and points to push our
thinking further along.
So I think that whether
it's thinking carefully
about what the treatments
are manipulating,
what's (indistinct) giving us,
what's something we can clarify.
To these bigger questions about the theory
that the paper is trying to develop,
I mean, I think, as Professor Nye
and Repnikova grip and a
bunch of people suggested,
thinking over time and how this changes
and how, as Professor Catalinac suggested,
how governments are
actually doing this can help
to answer this question
that Mike Tomz asked about,
"What's theoretically interesting...
"What's theoretically interesting here?"
So this has given us
great food for thought.
I really appreciate it.
I'm mindful however
that everyone was promised a Zoom break.
And so, I do want to stick to that
while still giving the next
paper presenters ample time
to discuss their really
excellent, exciting paper.
So as planned, let's try
to come back at 08:40.
So it gives us a slightly
shorter break than planned
but still maybe a little
time to walk around
and get away from our screens.
So, thanks again so much
and I'll see everybody
in about eight minutes.
Thank you.